patrice is the greatest i i've ever seen
my favorite but a lot of people would be
like yo patrice was kind of an [ __ ]
but you couldn't deny him patrice wasn't
an [ __ ] to everybody that's yeah
that's fast he was always nice to me
yeah because he thought you were a real
one bro he's nice patrice was nice he
was just you had to be able to don't
[ __ ] joke you had to be able to take
a joke you got to be able to take it
right on the chin and laugh right back
what did he say joe oh he was always
funny always he was just always funny
about everything he patrice had a way of
looking at things where we would all
talk and they would wait for patrice's
point
he's one of those guys if you talked to
patrice and hung out with him
i hung out with him in vegas once we
were all at the backstage at one of
those opium anthony shows
he was just such a i remember hanging
out with him going man i wish i lived
closer to him yep
yep who's that guy you know yeah but
luckily i had joey diaz joey joey's your
guys coach patrice yeah
yeah
he was very much like that joey diaz was
very much like that like we would all
line up the back of the room when joey
diaz was lighted on fire yeah tr and all
the people i've ever seen kill i'd never
seen anybody hit joey diaz rpms
he would hit he would have these bits
that they were so funny that you you
couldn't he could say things you weren't
allowed to say yeah because he was like
a human cartoon he did he weren't even
sure if he was real yeah yeah
this guy white is in spain
his timing was [ __ ] perfect and he
would nail punch lines and turn beat red
and people would be falling out of their
seats yeah
as multiple times i've been in that
original room where i'll go god i wish
we were filming this yeah i wish we were
filming this because i don't think i
don't think anybody's going to
understand if they're not here right now
you know you know fahim just put out his
special yes and uh shout out to uh go
check out hat trick but that's uh that
idea for the special that's what i
wanted to see i wanted to see joey do
that too and because joey for me i was
like you have to understand him within
the space of the store yeah
like he i know there's something magical
about it and i didn't understand until i
went out there and i saw him for the
first time you had been telling me a lot
about him and i remember just sitting
and watching and it was uh yeah it was
special man i'm working with joey in
atlantic city this weekend for the first
time in years i've been on stage with
him in like two years
i got to watch him yeah yeah i do i told
him like you did whatever you want to do
what do i have to do
to [ __ ] get you back in there i'm
like dude is this his first time back on
no no he's been on stage a bunch of
times okay good he did uh a bunch of
shows with brian cowan and he's he's
tuned up he's ready to rock
i'm so excited yeah i can't believe we
got him back yeah
yeah joey's a [ __ ] beast he was like
you have like specific roles in like
these communities you know and the
comedy store community joey diaz was
just pure chaos
he just you would drop them in and like
during like the the drug joey days like
during the early days when he was like a
straight-up criminal he reminded me so
much of my friend johnny so much johnny
who's
the poor hustler
yeah yeah joey was like just like him
yeah like a wild dude from the streets
but like a good dude yeah like i knew he
was a good like a good solid dude and we
were friends like instantly and he would
come to the news radio set and he was a
gorilla back then i mean he was like you
know way thinner and like
[Laughter]
he was wearing a leather jacket built
like a football player
and all those nbc studio executives who
get mad because he was eating all of
their
snacks
okay
what the mentality is jesus jesus christ
i
is like 1996. yeah you know we were both
like you know i was probably like 28.
and joey was like a little older than me
we were in joey just got to la straight
from prison
he was yeah he's always in and out of
jail i think he was like running from
something in seattle he had to come back
to l.a like there's a warrant out for
him for the longest time he couldn't get
uh a passport to go places because all
the cred he kidnapped a drug dealer with
a machine gun fire wow no joey diaz did
real time joey diaz is uh but he's a
uniquely beautiful soul and even though
i knew all that [ __ ] that he did real
time and everything i knew i'm like i
know what you are i know what you are
you're a great guy who just had a crazy
life you collect these guys these these
guys are valuable
they're everything they're life man
those are sam kennison's those are the
richard pryors but why do you think
because they just they don't fit in and
that's how you see what it is for real
like if you're not a part of it you see
what it is for real because you don't
have to operate you're not based on the
part of that system yeah yeah yeah joey
diaz found his mother dead on the floor
when he was on acid no that's what he
was like 14 years old yeah
well yeah when you're part of a
community
yeah you're [ __ ]
your goosebumps just stand up you're
like what
yeah
so it's like those type of people from
that angst and that unusual view of the
world have to find themselves
yes and sometimes themselves is a little
outside of the norm it's outside of the
group they find it through the most
potent form of entertainment yeah all of
our
great
rock stars all of our great comics all
of our great hip-hop artists all of them
come from crazy backgrounds
not all of them obviously that's a big
generalization
but i'm trying to make my point
no i understand what you're saying i
think they don't get it joey diaz in a
suburb yeah yeah but but more it's like
there's a there's a freedom
to being outside if you're willing to
harness yes and the freedom is you get
to actually find who you are well the
reality is there's no real outside like
people feel like they're outside but so
many people feel like they're outside
there's a lot of people
and when you go to a comedy club all the
other people also feel like they don't
get it they laugh at your point they go
yes yes
yes
yeah and even if if even it's what
you're saying is wrong but it's funny
it's like that's where it's like we're
[ __ ] with the wiring one of my
favorite bits that you do is that bit do
you do about countries where they treat
their women
got the best food
canadian food
that is so good
because like you look if you were a
terrible person you wanted to
misrepresent who you are you would write
that oh this is just saying that women
belong in the kitchen yeah
yeah that's not what they're saying no
it's not what you say you're saying
something funny it's a funny thing to
say i was trying i did this talk like
gnome from the comedy seller do you know
no yeah you would love gnome like you
got it okay good i worked his club way
way way i know but he's he's like he's
an interesting guy no andre should
connect you with noah
i can get you audition at the comedy
cellar like
yeah
shout out to all these uh comedy club
owners without them he had a he had an
interesting conversation he had this
like talk where there were these like
intellectual dudes this guy named glenn
lowry do you know
yeah so him and a few other dudes and uh
and they had some comics on stage and
we're just talking about you know random
things and comedy and political
correctness and culture etc and uh
and there was like just it was just like
a moment on stage where i was talking
like we should never be together like we
don't have to have these conversations
because you guys say what's right and we
say what's funny and i think what
happens is the people that say what's
right expect the people to say it's
funny to be right
and that's where our jokes become
more than jokes and where we get in
trouble if we're just out here just
making jokes and talking [ __ ] and just
being funny with no stakes that's wha
and then people look at us and they're
like oh no these are the next
intellectuals they are going to tell us
how to think that's when we can't make
the craziest jokes well one of the
arguments is that like if you say crazy
things in the name of being funny then
other people that are not as smart as
you
will say those things and they'll be
hurtful they'll feel like they have
license to say those things maybe i had
a drag queen tell me that after show
maybe
it was very intimidating
she was wearing kiss boots
uh but it's one of those things like i
don't know if you're responsible for the
dumbest people in your arm you're not
i don't know how that works you're not i
i feel like
at a certain point in time we have to
agree
that we most people love comedy if you
don't love comedy you have to opt out of
this conversation so if you love comedy
you must agree that a lot of what people
say they don't mean they just think it's
a funny thing to say like this is an
article
just like quentin tarantino is not
really killing women when he's making
once upon a time at home this is what
he's going to say about there's no dead
women involved in the production of that
movie correct the violent movies violent
rap eminem getting all those things
let's just move toward comedy it'll move
on but it's also like it's the problem
is it seems like you're just talking
mm-hmm it seems like it's not like
something you've created that you've
manipulated language in order to get a
surprise result that makes people go
yeah and it seems like your statements
because they sound just like everybody
else when they talk
yes but i also think it's because that's
how we feel and we can have wrong
feelings and i think that's the biggest
difference what's wrong though if you
feel it
like you don't have somebody might cut
you off in traffic and you might think
the worst possible thing for that car
and then three seconds later you go ah
it was just upset in the moment there's
i mean don't be people like get out of
don't people like uh oh yeah they don't
get life in jail for murdering somebody
because they had moments of rage you
know what that's from temporary
temporary insanity you know you know
whatever that's what comedy is temporary
and standard if this is my crazy thought
in the moment and then i'm going to say
it again and it's going to be funny but
i don't feel that way anymore
simple as that
what are you saying comedy is temporary
my funniest moment my funniest thought
and my knee-jerk reaction to something
and i'm going to craft it and add words
and add ideas and wrap myself around it
no what what
marijuana might not be for you
you would try to defend some
insufferable position
yo
the joke about the woman food thing i
don't think you should i don't think you
should actually say he was a wrong
position he said it was insufferable no
that's a great word
you can throw people off your trail
it's like it's like covering your your
traps with leaves cracked
it's a solid word if you're trying to be
deceptive
you know trying to infestate obfuscate
whatever
hey somebody somebody got a high score
in his essay let's go bro yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] it
yeah [ __ ] it dude let's just make the
jokes who gives a [ __ ] what anybody says
about it they want to write think pieces
who gives a [ __ ]